مين مننا لمن دخل الجامعه ما استنى لحظه
التخرج وحفلات التخرج والاحتفال بالانجاز
لكن في جامعه سودانيه واقفل طلابها يعني
امام هذا الحلم بنتكلم تحديدا عن الجامعه
الوطنيه في السودان الاعلانات الحرب على
حفلات التخرج الخاصه مو بس الحفلات كمان
الزفات ومواكب الخريجين والاحتفالات في
القاعات والغناء والرقص كله كله هذه
الاشياء يعني باختصار كل مظاهر الاحتفال
التخرج واصدره الجامعه قرار بمنع اقامته
ومشاركه الطلاب باي فعاليات واحتفاليات
بالتخرج خارج الحرم الجامعي وسمه الموضوع
بدعه محليه مو بس كده كمان الزمن الطلاب
هيوقعوا على التعهد اللي شايفينها امامكم
واللي بيقولوا فيه اعلم انه حفلات التخرج
اللي بتنظمها الشركات بتدعم محليه لا توجد
في اي مؤسسه التعليم عالي في العالم
واتعهد امام ولي امري ما اشارك في اي حفله
الا الرسمي او شركه الرسمي وفي حال خالفت
خلال او بعد التخرج فوافق على ايقاع اي
عقوبه تقررها رئاسه الجامعه او المجلس
العلمي علي بما يحفظ سمعه خريجيها وسمعه
مجتمع المعرفه في كل مكان
يعني كلام مره كبير الصراحه يعني لو
الطلاب احتفلوا برج الجامعه مع نفسهم او
كل واحد عمل حفله يعني وين المشكله يعني
ايش علاقه سمعه الخريجين ههه ولا سمعت معك
يعني
ههه
القرار قسم الشارع في السودان في ناس من
رايي انا مو فاهمه سبب الحرب على
الاحتفالات هذه وفي ناس مع القرار ومرحب
جدا وطالبه حتى بتعميمه وعلى كل الجامعات
يلا بلا فرح بلا احتفال